[Musique]
pour le droit de flâner pour le droit
des rues à vivre les rues ou les
passages où les hommes se rencontrent
parle sans courir les galeries
marchandes avait ce rôle dans les
grandes villes à marseille lyon ou paris
on les redécouvre aujourd'hui pour aller
de la bourse à la place des victoires au
musée du louvre par exemple on peut
passer par ici ou par là en empruntant
les galeries marchandes plus ou moins
fréquentées suivant leur et le dynamisme
des commerçants qui les autres sont les
avantages d'une galerie et clients sont
à l'abri de la pluie
ils peuvent flâner facilement n'y a pas
de voitures potes de bicyclettes sont
tranquilles on les laisse tranquilles à
l'étalagé regarde bouquiner il ya des
gens qui reste une heure une heure et
demie il y en a qui reste cinq minutes
ils sont pressés dirait qu'ils pensent
de trois heures
c'est passage présente évidemment bien
les avantages mais encore faut-il les
trouver
vous connaissez le quartier il ya
quarante ans que j'y suis et le passage
véro dodat où sont in satin j'ai causés
mais
trois ponts des ses galeries marchandes
forme pour les promeneurs parisien
plusieurs kilomètres de zones abritées
hélas tellement morcelé qu'il est
difficile de se fixer un itinéraire
précis
nous sommes ici au paradis des flâneurs
et des curieux car en nul autre lieu de
la capitale
plante pourrait trouver au mètre carré
un tel potentiel de dépaysement
la boutique de monsieur fait vrai tout
d'abord où depuis plus d'un siècle des
ouvriers fabriquent les pipes sous les
yeux des passants
[Musique]
et
la collection de poupées de robert capio
l'antiquaire spécialiste des jouets
anciens
et puis madame gervaise la lingère
blanchisseuses de fin à l'effet que l on
les fait à la da compte qu'on peut pas
les envoyer aux faux collier parce que
je vois spécialiste de linge un bal nash
face à selena tous que tout ce qu on a
dû vous preniez shirt rouge france
figure époque on va travailler alors ça
c'est fort c'est une chaîne puisque
effet la machine
ces deux fronts disent eh ben moi je
prend 3,75
[Musique]
on trouve encore dans ses galeries un
luthier de 23 ans daniel signé dans la
spécialité et la restauration des
viennent et puis une martyre authentique
du moins la firme tél huguette spengler
peintre et mécène locataires de cinq
boutiques où depuis huit ans elle n'a
rien vendu
l'artiste est en deuil ainsi que ses
statuts depuis la réception d'un avis
d'expulsion et tous se crêpe noir doit
regretter les acheteurs éventuels
[Musique]
bien sûr nous n'avons pas encore parlé
de madame georges artisans sur soi ni du
poète de 80 ans contrôleur d'humilité
mais la plus grande joie qu'offrent ces
passages c'est encore la découverte
alors si le coeur vous en dit
[Musique]